you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme a record number of
people are forced to leave their homes
because of disasters linked
to climate change our warmer
temperatures could be opening up
new divisions in the arctic
and we meet the award-winning ghanaian
environmental activist
campaigning against coal
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those developing the solutions
and coming up why angelina jolie is
calling for more women to become
beekeepers but first climate disasters
caused
more internal displacement than war last
year
the norwegian refugee council's internal
displacement monitoring centre
found three times the number of people
were forced to leave their homes by
events such as storms
floods and wildfires than by violent
conflict
last year a total of 40.5 million people
were internally displaced that's the
highest level
on record of that more than 30 million
were displaced by disasters such as
cyclones storms floods or wildfires
while 9.8 million people were forced
from their homes because of conflict or
violence
and if we look at which countries had
the highest number of disaster driven
internal displacements
afghanistan is at the top with more than
a million displaced due to
weather-related or geophysical events
then india is next followed by pakistan
ethiopia
and sudan well africa correspondent john
sparks is here with
more so john just how much of an issue
is this for africa
hi and yeah this is an absolutely huge
issue as this report
makes clear it's a sort of annual census
for the uh displaced
earlier this year we saw 700 000 people
who'd fled from their homes in northern
mozambique they were forced to
more southerly area trying to eke out a
livelihood
in an agricultural area that really
wasn't fit for fit for farming
and these weather-related events they
form a big part of this
report in central and eastern africa
people have been
suffering from two years of
unprecedented rainfall and
flooding the continent's largest lake
lake victoria now experiencing
record breaking water levels that has
flooded out communities in uganda
and kenya and it has sent a huge amount
of water
down the nile that water has broken the
banks
in countries like south sudan and we've
just returned from a reporting trip
there
we saw huge agricultural areas turned
into a
inland sea with farmers who had used to
work the agricultural land there turned
into fishermen trying to eke out
survival fishing
on their fields quite extraordinary
scenes john sparks thank you
in today's other climate news the
european commission has approved a 22.5
billion euro polish scheme to develop
green energy
under new plans an offshore wind farm
will be built along the country's
coastline to expand its renewable power
capacity
at the moment more than 70 percent of
poland's power is generated from coal
[Applause]
the national trust will create 5 000
acres of new woodland over the next four
years the charity will use a four
million pound donation from hsbc to
plant
two million trees which they say will
lock in over a million tons of carbon
from the atmosphere
it's part of efforts to create woodland
areas that will regenerate naturally in
the future
a giant piece of ice has broken off
antarctica to become the world's
largest iceberg the european space
agency confirmed the slab of ice
similar in size to the island of majorca
has dropped off the western edge of the
ron
ice shelf into the weddle sea the
iceberg is officially known as the a76
after the
antarctic quadrant where it was first
seen
and you can hear more about this story
with climate scientist dr ella gilbert
on our instagram
at sky news
[Applause]
and it's world b day and angelina jolie
is encouraging people to protect
our fuzzy friends the actor is part of
women in bees a
five-year program launched by the un
that trains women to be beekeepers
angelina says teaching women these
skills will benefit their
local communities as bees are vital to
our environment
now the arctic is believed to hold up to
a quarter of the earth's undiscovered
oil and gas and with the impact of
climate change
melting ice is offering new
opportunities to exploit natural
resources
and open up shipping routes over the
past two days foreign ministers from
arctic nations have come together at the
arctic
council which will be chaired by russia
for the next two years
it is important to focus on preserving
the biodiversity of the arctic its
unique ecosystem
on preventing marine and land pollution
we are prepared for
improving our practical interaction to
jointly respond to these challenges and
a number of others
against the backdrop of climate change
ensuring sustainable and safe
maritime activities in the arctic is of
particular importance
with the rapid development of navigation
we see
diversification of transport routes
between the atlantic and the asia
pacific region
well moscow correspondent diana magna
joins us now so diana what difference
could
russian chairmanship of the arctic
council make
well i think russia is the largest
arctic state so it stands to
suffer the most from climate change
especially in terms of melting
permafrost
but also to benefit in large part from
what you've just mentioned
possible mineral extraction as the ice
melts in the north and also
the opening of shipping lanes the
northern sea route
and the arctic council has always been
quite an effective forum of
cooperation between the arctic states
but there have been concerns that
russia's
military buildup in the arctic and that
concern goes both ways too
russia is extremely concerned about nato
exercises
close to its northern border says that
it should be able to defend its arctic
coast
especially as the ice retreats
and today said that it wanted to revive
military talks
as part of the arctic council's agenda
now whether that actually happens is
another story
they were suspended in 2014 and the
other arctic states
may not be particularly keen but
fundamentally today we heard
that there is a commitment to wanting to
keep this a place of low tension
and all the states are behind that diana
magnay thank you
now sky ocean rescue and the wwf are
launching an
interactive map to raise awareness of
what lives on our coastlines
and they found more than 80 percent of
people are unaware of just how many
marine species are living in the uk
seas it includes more than 40 species of
shark
atlantic puffins and bottlenose dolphins
wwf's executive director of advocacy and
campaigns kate norgrove
explains how the map will work
it's going to help marine enthusiasts
all over the country for orcas seagrass
water marshes seals whales dolphins
to name but a few and and can illustrate
how their habitats are under threat
and the map also lifts out ways that the
public can do uh can help to do their
bit to preserve the uk's ocean
and you can take a look at the sky ocean
rescue interactive map for yourself just
head to wwf.org dot uk
ocean heroes now
strawberry season has officially begun
in the uk but it's later than usual
due to the cooler winter and spring that
we've had it should have started at the
beginning of may but it's only this week
that some of the berries
are now ready for picking there's an
advantage to this because the longer
they spend ripening
the bigger and juicier the fruits are
about
70 percent of all strawberries bought in
the uk are grown by
farmers here but the unpredictability of
growing conditions due to climate change
is having an effect now if strawberries
from the uk
aren't available then they're imported
usually from spain the netherlands and
belgium there's a way that strawberries
can be harvested here almost all year
round by growing them in big plastic
tunnels or glass houses
but that of course needs artificial heat
and electric heaters are only as green
as their fuel supply well animal making
jones is a farmer in harrogate and she
joins me now um
welcome to you i know that you aim to be
carbon neutral in your strawberry
growing so what does that involve
so we are under tunnel but outside so we
don't use any artificial heat
we literally rely on the sunlight to
warm
the tunnels which is generally about two
degrees warmer
than the outside weather and the impact
it's had on us is that we've had frost
uh up until early may and it has damaged
some of the flowers which has killed
some of the
some of the fruit already so although
we're going to see bigger fruit with
what's left
we've already lost quite a large amount
of crop
and am i right i'm thinking that you've
got different species to try to
lengthen out the season as long as you
can
yes you grow several varieties
throughout the season
to try and get that may to october um
for supply and to retailers however
if it becomes cold earlier in september
your season is
shortened hugely by you know three weeks
late in may and then
not getting to mid-october you lose all
of that yield which means you know
you're not producing as much fruit and
therefore your cost goes up
and tell us a bit more about your
sustainability because i know you go to
some lengths
to make sure that you are sustainable
yeah so we're doing many things so using
our waste rhubarb waste strawberries and
turning them into jams and chutneys
we also make non-alcoholic low sugar
healthy drinks
and freeze them for the catering
industry so we are trying to collaborate
with other people too so a gin company i
use my strawberries with
to try and use every little bit that
we've got and really reduce our carbon
footprint
and then within the business we have
solar panels and we catch all our own
rain water so
we're totally self-sufficient annabelle
making jones thanks very much indeed
now in the latest of our series of
climate diaries we're meeting chabazi
ezekiel
it was because of his four year long
campaign that the ghanaian environment
ministry
cancelled the construction of a huge
coal power plant
and now he's working with youngsters to
help them get involved in the fight
against climate change
we are at a breaking point and we need
to work
now and fast even though young people
are vulnerable to the input of climate
change
young people can also become the change
agents that we need to address
the climate impact when the government
expressed his desire to build a copland
i led the campaign you know again and
koplan proposing
renewable energy as a better alternative
as compared
to coal plant
one of the things i've realized as a
campaigner is that
when you oppose comments or when you
critique comments decision
it is also important to provide an
alternative you know to make you a
relevant contributor in the process
so whilst we're campaigning against
school we are proposing renewable
energies as better alternatives
i have seen farmers losing their farm
because of severe landfall patterns
the whole community actually submerged
by the sea
because of sea level rise now seeing
people migrating because of the severe
impact of climate change
in my campaign or in my advocacy work i
work largely with young people
so that their voices can be heard so
they can also influence
decision making from the local level to
the national level and thankfully
we are making progress in our regard the
kumamoto gonna
listen to us and now stop the planet
with equipment and now focusing more
on developing and utilizing renewable
energies in ghana
and this process is purely generated
created implemented and deployed by
young people to showcase that young
people
have what it takes to prove their
climate agenda
that's all from us tomorrow on the daily
climate show why brazil's environment
minister is being investigated
over claims of illegal timber exports
thanks for watching
see you then
you